okay Dantley why there that I cannot
dance
I'm just wondering how could I be so far
oh hello it's Monday
hello and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it on the breeze like these
leaves I must be gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]
and that's that right there excuse me
that is um bishop gun with shine and
that's a song right there by that band
and that can you imagine those boys from
Natchez Mississippi right now are out
there touring in Europe and that can be
some of the beauty of music man it hits
people's ears and and then it hits our
you know because the ear goes directly
the ear bone is connected to the hard
bone and it hits their ears and just
goes right into their heart and then
that feeling man and they want more of
that feeling and that's what those boys
are doing
Bishop Gunn is a band and they are in
Europe right now performing different
areas
I have speaking of that I've much I'm
gonna go I mean this is crazy I can't
even believe I'm gonna be saying these
words I'm gonna be going uh we locked
down a date in London that's crazy man
just to hear myself say those words that
I'm gonna be going to I mean we're
Americans came from let's be honest
about it you know America started
because [ __ ] wasn't going that great in
England you know people were being mean
to each other in England they had
bullying people was doing bullying and
the next thing you know people said you
know what [ __ ] you bruh I'm out and they
got in a boat and left and
and the people in England like way you
go in and they're like we don't even
[ __ ] know
so things must have been hairy if
somebody left and didn't even know where
they're going that's when you know you
you just got to go but I'm happy to be
coming back to that original homeland
over there a miracle 1.0 England excuse
me and I don't know when that'll be yet
out while I do know the date but I'm not
looking at that there gonna be other
dates around it you know there will be
Scotland and Ireland and [ __ ] dude I
can't even imagine do that's so crazy
I'm gonna be going over there so anyway
I don't mean to make this myself about
myself out of the gate but I just you
know I am excited and I deserve to feel
feel good sometimes and I'm excited
about that
who's listening out there that's what I
want to know who's listening to this
this podcast - this past weekend thank
you guys for being here with me who's
listening who are you I want you to hit
the hotline on nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three are you uh you
know we used to have a lot of postman a
lot of post men would hit the hotline
and let us know and you know we had a
lot of drivers I remember we had a FedEx
driver that you know but who are you who
are you listening hit the hotline and
say hey you know my name is this and
this is what I do for work and this is
when I listen to this past weekend I
would just love to know that you know I
can't my name is Theo and you know and I
listened to the podcast in the morning
when I do stretches on my floor in my
bedroom that's what I do I mean that's
just definitely a little bit you know
something with tender gentlemen would
say but that's when I listen so hit the
hotline I just want to know who's out
there listening I want to know you know
always hear so much you guys always hear
so much about me I want to hear
more about you what's going on a lot you
know I just got back I flew back this
morning from Atlantic City we had I went
and did some shows and they had theater
shows and I'm talking theaters boy you
know theaters you know and if a lot of
times when you are if somebody talks
real fast they even say my name like
that
oh that's theatre instead of Theodore
they're like oh that's theater right
there and we did the shows we went to
Medford and that was the first one was a
and the crazy thing a theater I didn't
go look at the stage in advance and the
lights are so bright you can only see
about first two rows of people and there
was maybe you know I don't even know how
many people in that place I mean it
seemed like a damn Community College it
felt like that [ __ ] was pretty big and
people were doing you know it smelled
like weed and everything so yeah very
much like Community College and and III
didn't know like how deep it was man I
was it was kind of scared it was like I
felt like a like a hamster that had to
also a I felt like ode have you ever
seen a prison movie where's the prisoner
gets out and they have the big spotlight
and they're shining it looking for him I
felt like that guy like that prisoner
but also what if you gave that prisoner
a microphone and while he's running off
he have to tell jokes so that's how I
felt and man it was it but it way you
know it was a crazy just three three
nights and then did two shows at the
ball Wilbur theater in Boston and then a
show in Atlantic City and we took planes
and trains and automobiles and we didn't
have anybody to host for any of the
shows so a couple hours before I'm just
asking people like hey do you know
anybody that lives
the area that can do comedy and next
thing you know we found a host you know
a young fella named Andrew who came out
for the Boston shows and that dude is
sitting there you know at his home
probably you know I'm not saying doing
masturbation but probably doing a little
and next thing you know he's on stage in
front of 1,500 and so hey you know and
he did a great job you know we just hit
up literally like whereas does anybody
know anyone in this area that can do it
and then the same thing for the Atlantic
City we just got you know does anybody
know anybody in the area who can drive
over here and do some comedy for 10
minutes at the beginning of the show but
man it was wild it was um I mean it was
awesome it was scary though I felt
pretty scared uh because I just don't
you know it's like being in a new place
it's like um I'm trying to think of
exactly how it feels you ever uh you
ever go remember if you ever gone to
look at an apartment or a house and you
go in and there's no furniture in and
you're just going to check it out you
know maybe to see if you'll move there
or or you know or something and you go
in and you you're going in the different
rooms and you just kind of it feels new
it feels different the first time you've
ever felt the space and felt your body
react to the distance between you and
the walls and just the space and that's
what it feels it feels like that going
on the stage but so you have that kind
of feeling you're in a new space but
then you also at the same time have a
you know some responsibilities and so
yeah it was just it was a different
animal you know I'm so used to being an
interest in a comedy club and and I'll
still be doing a lot of clubs it was
just it was just kind of how the weekend
worked out but thank you so much to
everybody that came out you know we had
a couple of brothers that came out
actual brothers people that were you
know
mates and also a couple of black
gentlemen we have one young fella look
like I thought it was Sean Kingston and
he came out to one of the shows I don't
know if you remember sean kingston he i
think he might have killed alia with
that damn sea-doo or whatever but he
came out what else did we do dude it was
a curette like so I went to the barstool
sports and people say barstool you know
they have you know they're basically
people they put stuff on the Internet
you know say if your aunt does a hit you
know does a couple whippets and
accidentally gets [ __ ] up and kisses
her son or something like that like at a
foosball tournament or whatever then
they put that [ __ ] on barstool videos so
that you know I went to their office and
it was pretty crazy I've rolled in there
and they got an older black gentleman
sitting right there and he was polishing
off a little bit of rib meat or
something and this dude was you know he
was half a cage deep into some [ __ ]
ribs but I don't know if you know if you
don't have any black friends then you
never seen how black men can really get
into some ribs do black guys should be
orthopedist um or the Orthodox or
something I'm surprised they're not more
black surgeons because you see a black
dude get into a thing of ribs bro like
dang dude do you I didn't even know they
had all that in there a black out crack
a rib open and do it they got meat in
there so if you never had a black friend
anyway if you first of all get a black
friend and then what get order him half
of rack of ribs and see what he does
that mother that dude will have them
[ __ ] dry at the end of it no not a
meat not a not a gristle you could dip
that thing on a black man could dip a
rib that he ate into a fish tank and not
even a little fish not one fish
swim up to even look for anything
because there's nothing on it so you
know when it comes you know a black guy
you know will really put that gang bang
on a rib he'll [ __ ] tighten that
thing up to the fullest so this guy
anyway I'll roll into the office at
barstools the man is sitting in there
and he's supposed to be the guy that
like checks you in downstairs at the
bottom of the deal at the ground floor
so he looked up at me like he was pissed
that I was there so I was like [ __ ] it
bro you know you don't want to do your
job you know whatever so I went past
that guy went up to the third floor and
the elevator doors open and there's like
maybe 50 dudes you know a lot of them
look like maybe they played you know
half of them kind of look like maybe
they played lacrosse or something for
not Duke you know not that you know the
sexual team but may at least you know at
least maybe UNC or NC State and uh and
then yeah they got next you know there's
a camera guy pops up and they got a lady
cutting up a grapefruit and they have a
couple little studios and it's just it
was wild to see cuz you know what it's
like seeing behind the Internet
it's like it the doors open and then
there's like you know 50 guys sitting
two computers and and it was a good vibe
we went in there and did the radio show
and then I stopped I went that night and
I and it was it was just a good vibe man
I had fun in there and and if you
haven't if you get a chance to go listen
to that episode when I was on their
radio it was a lot of fun actually so
I've really enjoyed that and then what
else happened trying to tell you what
happened this past weekend oh then I
stopped by the Comedy Cellar that night
in New York to see some different
comedians and just say hey I got to
watch Dave Attell perform so that was
awesome and that guy he once referred to
heard him refer to he refer to peanut
butter as as
um oh he referred to hummus as Isis
peanut butter and I thought that was
pretty much right on time so that was it
and then the next day we did the the
next morning I went to Boston did the
shows I did it shows that Medford the
guy Francis this big guy
white dude you know pretty rich bro like
even his breath kind of smelled like
Cologne a little you know the kind of
guy that has breakfast and probably has
a little bit of [ __ ] you know some
mom you know a little fan you know some
Estee Lauder sense or something on his
pancakes
the kind of dude who have a nice you
know a couple of omelets and wash it
down with a [ __ ] mouthful of you know
Garnier Fructis or something one of
those you know a fancy deal so Francis
was there at first of all of you named
after you know Francis what you know
Francis that's crazy you got to be rich
to really have a you know kind of a
bigender name and be a man this dude was
a handsome guy to look like one of those
winklevosses remember the winklevosses
who almost beat up that guy a facebook
kid him so we he came on and did the
shows with us and it was just blast man
so many people came out so many people
came out here we got a cop we got one
guy right here he came to the Medford
said let me hit this off and this guy
left a voicemail on the hotline so let
me see what he had to say you know
what's up man my name is Jared what's up
Jared thanks for thanks for calling us
sir I'm a little tired you have to
forgive me today Jared homeward
Connecticut I saw you up in Medford man
awesome show super grateful that you
came out I appreciate you you know
staying after to meet with everyone
after the show you know I'm the
gentleman that had the match in
Mississippi mud flap in the flannel you
know oh yeah bro you had that tight
tight cut and you had that fool that
backsplash on the neck dude and you had
real short that short short front hair
you know
almost going out of business in the
front but still partying in the back you
know you had that real WOM like if you
see like a young young kid who has a
kind of a mullet haircut him I mean he's
kind of standing on the side of the road
and none of his parents are with him and
he's kind of throwing rocks into a ditch
or something you had that style that
old-school neighborhoods style that I
grew up around let's hear more you know
I think you for your encouragement man
on my recovery man just celebrated 19
months clean and I love you know I love
how you were giving me some motivation
man and what the podcast my boy and I
listen to what it gets us through the
week gives us something to talk about
and just don't want to say thanks again
man Gang Gang man Thank You bud and
congratulations do 19 months think about
that dude a lot of stuff happened 19
months anything could happen you could
go to jail frog you know probably a
manslaughter if you had a good attorney
and get back out anything could happen
you could have a 19 month old child so
man congratulations dude I'm glad that
you're I'm glad that you came out man
and yeah I remember that haircut I
definitely you had that [ __ ] like a
lesbian that really she's you know
devout lesbian like she some time in her
life she's gonna find a way to really
sprout a dick you know if she wants to
it's gonna be up to her and I do
remember that cut man that [ __ ] was
beautiful and you know I noticed a lot
of guys sometimes it about growing the
long hair out the back it's like a mane
it's just like a little it's almost like
it's like the only thing we can do these
days you know are not the only thing I
shouldn't say that but as men it's like
something we can do to express our
masculinity because I do feel like in
some ways you know masculinity is just
uh it's not at a crossroads but it is at
a time when it needs to be tempered in
some spaces because you know it's
it's not fair because our environment
our society has become a lot more
structured a lot less primal and so it
you know you have to you have to temper
the flames of that wild masculinity back
in the day dude think about when you
know 1700 you could take your wife for a
hike and never bring her back and that
was nothing you know you could shoot
your neighbor and now what you know Oh
where's my [ __ ] rake you know mr.
Daniel and next thing you know pop pop
and that's it so which is just a
different time so now it's like we got
to temper it out a little bit and and
yes of one thing that men can do is grow
is you know it's just sprout that spout
grow that back hitter and go [ __ ]
hard in that neck paint or actually go
soft in that neck paint you know because
my [ __ ] guy do you touch the back on my
hair feels like [ __ ] nine babies it
looked like it feels like nine babies
just rubbing a little chamois cloths on
each other just soft soap in each
other's shoulders dude it's like nine
babies in a [ __ ] soft pile with
butter on them I met could you imagine
putting butter on a baby
yeah damn bro you know I'm not a um a
cannibal but if you put [ __ ] butter
on him Behav broth wouldn't be surprised
if I [ __ ] took a little bite out of
that guy but man congratulations man and
I'm happy to you and your friend find
some joy and listening to me and uh and
I found joy and you guys haven't come
out man it's good I had fun did I had
someone do the first show in Boston I
had so much fun in in at the Wilbur the
first one I mean all the shows I tried
my best but that first Wilbur show man I
had so much fun I just and then the
second one I think I got a little you
know I got nervous
the crowd was rowdier in the metal and I
think I was just a little Scout did my
best but I was just a little scared but
but man it was overall it was a great
experience I mean it's just a learning
experience to be in that space I'm glad
that I had people every people after the
shows were super supportive but that
seconds to the Late Show in Medford I in
at the Wilbur you know how if I could
have won back that I could just do some
parts of it over or just I don't know
the vibe was just it wasn't bad and it
had nothing to do with the audience it
just it just I could I was just I don't
know I just wish I could do it again but
you know I'm hard on myself and that's
okay sometimes that's okay sometimes um
what else happened this past weekend man
I'm trying to think oh I got my back
waxed that felt pretty good
I didn't get much sleep oh my gosh so
one of the guys from Whitesnake was on
the plane back with me to Los Angeles
and they're the ones who did the fire at
that building and a lot of people died
r.i.p from that Whitesnake fire back
there near providence a long time ago oh
man what else what else can I tell you
about I can tell you about this episode
is brought to you by gray block pizza
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach gray block pizza
get that yeah I was gonna tell you this
the guests we have coming up Mark
Geragos and he's an attorney he's that
Atticus Finch you know he's that [ __ ]
that gavel E bad boy he's out there you
know he's out there shaping troops and
vinden lies and he's represented on
Michael Jackson Colin Kaepernick Scott
Peterson the man that killed everybody
Chris Brown and and you can send in your
video questions about about any
questions you have for that man for Mark
Geragos he'll be in here I thought he
was the swimmer then almost died of HIV
when he hit his head on the arm
on the board but um anyway he'll be in
here and we'll be putting some swipe up
so you guys can swipe up and sit in a
question for him as well we have Bryan
Callen will be coming in so we're going
to be doing uh we're going to be doing
an episode we're gonna we'll ask for
some submissions for him we're gonna
he's gonna take us through like a March
Madness version of the state Wars like
if all the states got into war like if
it became all the states became you know
it was an onion off' I'd America on
United States and there were state Wars
like March Madness style with brackets
and they all fought off against each
other and who would win and Bryan
Callens is a very smart man and that's
um Brendan Schaub his daddy Brendan is
the man that does King in the sting with
me and he's the sting and and so so his
daddy is Bryan Callens and he does I
think he was in I don't think he was in
Vietnam he was in Korea you know and he
does a lot of stuff like that
AARP does the conferences and so he'll
be in here because he's very smart and
he's gonna help us out
and and take us through that that's
gonna be he and i's episode so if you
have a video or you can there's a link
in the youtube if you think why your
state would do well in this state wars
what they have to offer why you know you
know you could say oh I think Nevada is
gonna win because you know they have you
know troops could get up you know you
know they could take all the gambling
money and buy tanks or whatever so but
whatever your reason why you think your
state will win you can hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and we'll add some of those
some of those parts in to the episode
and and and we'll use them as we go
through the states oh man he had dude
this weekend was kind of scary in some
ways um you know I sometimes like you
know sometimes I feel like I don't like
talking about some [ __ ] because
you know this set before the second
Medford Show man I was sitting in the
back of the of the place and I was just
like kind of just got real emotional man
I was sitting back there and I just felt
scared I was just sitting back there by
myself and I just felt I don't know I
didn't feel good man you know to be
honest I was real teared up and you know
it's called yeah I just didn't feel okay
you know when I called a couple of
friends and fun thankfully somebody
answered and I was able to talk to him
and I was trying to think about why I
didn't and I think you know and I think
it was because sometimes inside of me
there's a thing where let's like I'm
afraid to feel good about myself because
it's almost just such an unfamiliar
territory that it makes me scared or
it's like if I feel good about myself
then it means I'm being selfish or
something you know I and I just I was
like excited about the theatres and and
then I just I don't know I just I don't
even know you know part of me doesn't
even know and maybe I'll talk a little
bit when I go over to my therapist this
week I'll try and talk to her about it
and think about it more but yeah I was
just you not a thorough sitting there
and I just felt like I just didn't feel
good you know I just didn't feel good
and some of that goes back to just you
know that's kind of like my alcoholism
or my thing inside of my lack of self
confidence that's inside of me somewhere
it just it's almost like this little
gremlin that way even when things are
good it wants to pop up and and control
the show it's like this little dirty
little man who's got a whip and he's you
know he's probably doing dirty stuff and
being like I maybe even a homeowner
that's a mean one you know when he's you
know it just gets in there and he he
just beats all my good feelings with a
whip and makes my good feelings feel
like they're bad or they've done
something bad
so I got some of that and I don't know
what the deal was but but I got some of
that going on but then you know I was
thankful you know I talked to a friend
and they and they made me feel better
and then I was and then I was okay and
then I was okay so anyway that's year I
I don't know I'm kind of all over the
place man I didn't get you know I flew
home I got off the plane I went home
arrested for 40 minutes and then I came
over here and uh and I want to try to
hit an a a meeting tonight so but I'm
grateful to be here with you guys and
and man so many people came out it was
crazy
I mean people came out a guy gave me a
nice shirt I didn't even get to unpack
my bag and bring it in here somebody may
owe some dude they had a Vietnamese this
this beautiful pair of vietze you know
they made a shirt and it said Vietnamese
are people not food and I thought that
was great because you guys know almost
bid into that kid at a Best Buy that
time oh let's get into the news a little
bit here Alex Trebek
announced in a video that he has Stage
four pancreatic cancer Trebek is 78
years old and is hosted jeopardy since
1984 said he intends to fight the
disease and work the rest of his
contract through 2020 - that's crazy -
you know it's really scary when people
start passing away that um that are part
of your life or that are part of your
childhood or just in your periphery of
existence you know it starts to remind
you how just how real life is and that
gets scary you know life is this very
you know it's is very it's like this
very real dragon kind of and you know
sometimes it hibernate for a while and
it's not there and and and and sometimes
it you know just [ __ ] out of nowhere
just way
sup and just black you know just burned
you with that [ __ ] face heat that
popper and and it's just it you know
sometimes you just kind of cruising down
the road of life and then life's like
guess what [ __ ] right turn
surprise [ __ ] you know intersection
without any stop signs just you know
[ __ ] like that
then it gets intense and uh and that's
the kind of thing I start to feel like
when people are passing away or people
are getting you know sick and older and
like it's like you want these little
things that are in the periphery of your
life these staples to always kind of be
there and just but it just keeps moving
on man but then that's the same thing
that adds value to it you know that's
the same thing that adds value to it is
that it's not a forever thing you know
you don't have unlimited life this [ __ ]
any breadsticks at Olive Garden dude you
know this is like at an at a place where
they just give you one or two breads and
they don't have extra if you want it I
mean life is just one or two breads you
know now they can have as much flavor in
them as you as you want to taste for you
can just try and take you know you can
eat them fast and that's it but if you
really want to get down to that dough
and get yeasty you can pop off and
really enjoy I mean you can break that
there's one or two breads down to every
[ __ ] ingredient and suck the egg and
the salt in them flour and the rise and
the yeast and the and some of them they
might be cinnamon bread raisin breads
you can you can really enjoy all at him
tastes in there or you can just gobble
em [ __ ] up beyond through it but it's
not unlimited breadsticks it feels like
it is or it is when you're really young
and then it's not
and I don't even know what I'm talking
about
former teen heartthrob and star of 90210
Luke Perry passed away at 52 after
suffering a massive stroke and dude I
remember watching nine oh two one oh
when I was young it was like the first
show that I got to watch it was called
Beverly Hills 90210 and it was about
rich kids and some poor kids that all
went to school together in Beverly Hills
and um and I remember doing that that
was like the first show were like there
was kind of something you know people
were having maybe sex or talking about
sex and I would sit there and like and
not my whole from my brothers and
sisters we would all watch it I think my
littlest sister wasn't allowed to watch
it but we'd sit there dude and I would
be just erect as hell you know I'll be
well I know who's the only TV show that
someone's have to face the other way and
then turn back and look at it you know
and watch because I didn't want people
seeing my body getting all hard in the
middle especially I had that ap bride
that [ __ ] rocking job you know I had
that [ __ ] DeMarcus Cousins you know
wiener even as a child I had that big
[ __ ] baby whale you know I had that
[ __ ] that Will Sasso that thick
hitchhiker you know it was like uh you
ever seen a mitten but the thumb is
twice as big as the finger part that's
kind of how like my nuts and wiener even
as a child you know I had that cat daddy
and so I'll you know it make me so
nervous because I would just have on
little shorts or tight you know
children's television pants you know
little what were those things called
little whoa you remember those it was
like a onesie and it had a little
trapdoor in the back in case you had to
do with duty real fast or something in
case it was a fire and the you know to
get out of the hole ones he they had
that little fire escape in the back okay
somebody threw a match on the front of
your pajamas and you had to [ __ ]
wiggle out of them [ __ ] they
that you know the you know that reverse
psychology just a way you could just say
bye-bye right out the back of young
short you know your own that onesie and
you could just you know you could save
your own life but but yeah I remember do
those things and suddenly I get so erect
the [ __ ] rest of the ones you would
get real tight on my body because I
don't have a lot of room in that [ __ ]
anyway you know I got that body type
I'll [ __ ] fill a onesie you know but
you know I got that limited neck you
know only got about a inch and a half
long neck but I did see this little neck
stretcher thing on Instagram the other
day so I might look at that I don't want
to thank everybody that sent me links to
that as well I had about 60 people that
sent me different links to that what
else man yeah but that show dude that
show was the first show where you would
see people kiss and her smooching I mean
you had like somebody had a convertible
car the only other dude I ever knew what
a convertible this dude named Eddie Joe
man he was like I think 16 or [ __ ] 40
and he lives in our neighborhood and he
had a couple of these girl they had
these two girls and they were sisters or
you know twins they might have been
[ __ ] conjoined I don't even know bruh
but these [ __ ] was really kind of
unraveled a little bit you know it
wasn't yeah I think they was premature
babies and premature twins you don't
know what's gonna happen dude you know
sometime you'll take a you know you take
one pie out of the oven and you have and
you're like oh man it was good but it
could have been better
you've taken [ __ ] two pies out the
oven dawg oh then you you know you
letting the devil [ __ ] live in the
desert and so that's the and sometime he
would be he would get these girls and
they both even had the same name I think
Janet you know double Janet's or
whatever and cuz the mom probably had a
limited name choices you know she wrote
down one name she might have been on a
couple of ludes and then seen it twice
on the sheet and said [ __ ] it son we're
gonna take our chances a name both of
these baby girls a little chance
and dude so this guy Eddie he had this
5.0 Mustang and I think it was even a
6.0 David I think he wrote on wrote a
six or put a six made out of like uh you
know well like a caulking or something
over the five so he's rolling in that
6.0 Ford Mustang convertible top and he
would give these girls he would get a
mom you know daiquiris or something
little milkshakes and he would just be
rolling these double janet's around town
and one time he was out front just
flexing and talking and we were out by
the street just talking to him and just
burning [ __ ] in the ditch you know this
you know just enjoying the summer and he
floored it and both of those broads
rolled right off the [ __ ] back boy
and man it was it was awesome and that's
when you knew they were twins they had
that I mean they both rolled off exactly
because they were sitting on the bat on
the top of the backseat with the
convertible down so then they're sitting
really on the back of the car almost on
the trunk with their legs into the car
and they were just flexing a sipping on
these little daiquiris little these
little you know cherry slushy throat
hitters and then he floored it or I
think he I think he was trying to hit
the brakes and he hit the wrong brake
the gas and those [ __ ] rolled right
off the back dude [ __ ] double janet's
right onto the [ __ ] concrete and it
was pretty cool man it was I mean it
wasn't the Olympics but that [ __ ] was
pretty legit I mean it was the closest
thing I'd ever seen the like I don't
remember if you remember the 1988
Olympics they had that little girl what
was her name I think like yeah Yana
Mogadishu or something and yacht Yana
Mogadishu was she was like the best you
know gymnastic well you know she was
that gymnastic ol crazy / you know she
could do anything she flipped you off
with her finger and then [ __ ] do nine
backflips and she did you know she would
flip you off and then [ __ ] flip off
into the distance and yeah Jana I don't
know yeah I know it was Mogadishu was
her last name and she would
you know she could do it all you know
she was the kind of girl who when she
was born she probably [ __ ] double jab
handspring right out of them womb you
know some people's breech and some
people are c-section and this bad [ __ ]
probably crawled right back up on her
you know she probably crawled right out
of her mom's throat and did a [ __ ]
you know that that [ __ ] right off the
top that [ __ ] Filipino shooting star
right off the top and just landed it
straight up into the doctors pocket I
mean she was you know an acrobat she was
an acrobat imagine if you put you know
an egg and semen and you know you said
Majan you put an egg and seed and uh
leotard and a you know a little bit of a
hand chalk into a cannon and just shot
that [ __ ] right out into the Olympics
that was her
yeah Yana Mogadishu uh maybe I can have
our producer out a picture of her to
this as well but [ __ ] I don't even I was
talking about man
oh but the show nine oh two one oh it
was the first show that you as a kid I
remember just seeing just like adult
things that were things that were just
ahead of my things that were happening
in my world you know like I remember
like the to hit the kids on the screen
there were teenagers they were in high
school even though they were in their
30s as a you know in real life but we
didn't know that as children and so 9:02
one knows man who would be on and we
would you know Brenda was about to kiss
Ryan or whatever Ronald and damn bro
secondly I would just [ __ ] be like
this and my sister would just start like
her neck would start shaking for no
reason and my brother but I don't even
know what he would do bruh he would pass
out we don't know I don't even know what
was going on dude I'd have a little
thing of Shasta and I drink the whole
[ __ ] can right then like I didn't it
was just there was too many you know
it's that young time in your life when
your chromosomes and your [ __ ] and
your nuts are even you know you're nuts
aren't even doing nothing at that point
you're nuts or does something you
[ __ ] kind of you know twist around
each other like this little you know
there's magic little time balls or
whatever to relax at night before you go
to bed you know you're nuts or nothing
you're nuts or just a place you think
your body's just storing you know extra
[ __ ] molars or whatever you don't
even know what your nut sack is at that
age and then you you know you're
watching this TV show and you see a
couple kiss for the first time and you
just working I'm [ __ ] drink nine cans
of watermelon Shasta and just just get
ready to piss in the bed dude it was
just that you know it was your what is
it called when your body gets so fired
up about something that it starts to
metastasize a little bit into something
else
hormones hormones and they put him in
milk too and sometimes I'll [ __ ] have
a little milk for a jerk-off just to get
back to that old-school feeling but
hormones man that was the thing you know
I'd be sitting there and you know
Stephen and you know um what was the
other girl's name in the show 9:02 one
Oh Stephen and [ __ ] I don't know Dylan
McKay was the one guy he was the fancy
guy he was like the Fonz he came in with
the jacket and he never kind of said
anything and he he was always too kind
of squinted his eyes and he was always
kind of he came up to the door and the
parents didn't really like him and then
he rode off on his motorbike he really I
think he might have had [ __ ] autism
bro and I don't think he probably
registered that bike because he was kind
of always in and out of this of [ __ ] you
never knew anything about him Luke Perry
his character Dylan McKay and he was in
love with [ __ ] Sandra or whatever
Jennifer Doherty and they would um and
they were always talking about doing sex
and when that [ __ ] what happened bro
because you got a picture of man we're
sitting there me and my two siblings and
you got Dylan McCain you got Jenny
Doherty they [ __ ] you know they're 30
in real life but we don't know what his
kids we think you know cuz I was
probably 11 my brothers you know 13 my
sister's 9 we're all sitting there and
this is the program that mom lets us
watch that she maybe shouldn't let us
watch but you know she wants to put a
little bit of lotion on her legs in the
other room and floss her teeth and
that's her time to be by herself
so this is what we get so we're sitting
there ready to watch Beverly Hills and I
know too one knows boy and and then they
start talking about sexual or you know
somebody [ __ ] you see a little bit of
a bra strap and next thing you know I
gotta [ __ ] lay it out of my bag dude
cuz I'm don't know what's going on
because my hormones are sternness just
mingle around my body and get to know
each other you know and suddenly my
burnt my brain is starting to say hello
to my dick but on the inside of my body
and this is before this like an internal
tender and everybody's [ __ ] swiping
right and it's just crazy you're by your
neck starts [ __ ] tightening up and
your dude I remember sometimes my arms
would go straight out to both sides of
my body for no reason I wouldn't even
know it was happening because on the
screen they had these young people and
you were feeling just sexual and we're
feeling keyed up and jacked up on your
own these little crystals man cuz God
puts these little [ __ ] crystals in your
body when you're born I guess and they
don't really kind of sprout until you
start to get sexual and that's hormones
and when those [ __ ] start popping off
it's like man it's like there's flavor
crystals in gum it's like you think it's
just gum and then BAM you hit that [ __ ]
and suddenly you know suddenly you have
diktats your dicks got fresh breath and
it's that kind of thing
that's them libido poppers though them
internal hitters and that's kind of what
happened when I would see these shows
we'd sit there and I would get I didn't
I
even know really what was going on I
just my brain would I couldn't close my
eyes or blink and I would just [ __ ]
drink two cans of Shasta you know man I
feel exhausted even thinking about it
now what else the toe I saw I saw this
episode the Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey
returned to the Joe Rogan experience and
brought his executive VJ a gig VJ Agati
who I think won American Idol season 2
runner up to debate journalist Tim Poole
on some of Twitter Twitter's policies
Rogan was heavily criticized for
dorsey's first appearance with many
believing Rogen did not ask hard enough
questions or cite specific examples of
Twitter's perceived bias I didn't see
the first episode so I don't know about
that that's just what was written on
this page here but I thought Tim Poole
did a good job of expressing the
thoughts of a lot of people you know and
I think in the end a lot of it just
comes down to you know a lot of media is
just as liberal it's very liberal and
it's very forward-thinking and it's it's
this you know one love and we can't say
anything bad and you know we but a lot
of media is based out of places where
that type of living is more of a reality
and when you get into other places
they're there the life there and the the
reality isn't the same but if you try to
share that your reality from those
places then that is looked at as as
being you know that it's all labelled as
conservative now it's you know it's some
of it is labelled as racist and it's
some of us labelled as sexist and it's
and and some things it's a mix of things
it's a mix of traditionalism it's it's
trying to express that there is racism
that they do have that [ __ ] sugar
racism out there in a lot of directions
you know you got Latinos and black
some blacks and whites and whites and
and whites and blacks and whites and
Latinos and you got [ __ ] everybody
wondering what Patrick my home's you
know what is he
you know everybody it's just but it's
like you got and it's just what to me it
seems like one part of the country just
can't share the reality and one part of
the country you know shares this like
ideology and the problem is there's just
two different realities going on in
America I think or there's more than two
there's a bunch but a lot of the media
so so far has been based out of places
where a lot of the reality is the same
but I think that's what you start to see
now that's different and I think you're
going to get to better conversations
when when you when you when more
realities have a voice and Twitter is
really means a lot of extremists on
there I mean you only read you can go to
Twitter I think is too if you really
keyed up to try to see a titty or
something or um if you want to really
argue with people or just throw
sometimes before bed I'll say something
[ __ ] up on Twitter and it's like
throwing a rock into a [ __ ] hallway
of of people that don't like rocks and I
just go to bed bro and just laugh it's
just it's an instigator it's paradise if
you like just bullshitting you know if
you like to leave a turd near the
[ __ ] caviar bro then Twitter is your
place to be man they got some fun dude
in it yeah excuse me it's bananas out
there I think it's hilarious I think
it's absolutely layers but I think it's
a good episode if you want to you know
everybody has some of their favorite Joe
Rogan episodes and that's one of my man
and Joe Rogan's got the best uh he's
just a curious listener he's a curious
man and he's active and uh but I thought
it was great I thought this was great
I thought doors he was a little he come
across a little soft to me but that's my
thought but I think that there is a
curbing of ideas or not
but even even the desire to discuss like
realities in some parts of America
traditional views or looked at it or
immediately labeled a certain way
because look I think it would be great
if everybody could live in a place I
don't think anybody doesn't want to live
in a place where everybody gets along
and everybody is healthy and
contributing I feel like that's
everybody's goal I feel like everybody
and I believe that everybody can be
helped except for some people cannot be
helped
some people that some core place in
themselves they do not want to help
themselves they do not want to
contribute they do not want to they
really don't want things to be good I
think as few but I think that some
people but I believe that most people
can be helped all of us including myself
[ __ ] yeah do you know my [ __ ] I'm
puckett if anybody's always waving the
hell flag it's your boy but uh but I
thought this was interesting I I do
think that and when you start to temper
that people can't share what their
reality is and what their life is
because it just doesn't fit with what
somebody else's life is and that person
has more ability to has like if one
person is a bigger projector and they're
able to say okay this is my life this is
the world this is the way it is and a
guy over here who who will probably
wants the same life that this other
person have with the big projector is
running that old-school projector where
they got to spin with their hand they're
saying but that's not the truth man
that's not that's not the truth don't
you see I'm showing you that that's not
the truth here but and then they start
to tell the man with a little project
you're not allowed to use those
projectors anymore or we're not letting
those projection we're not even letting
you show these images or these ID or
even discussions in in this bigger
projector universe scary I just don't
think that's it just because it doesn't
help it doesn't help us get our voices
out
it doesn't help people get there it
doesn't help anybody get there because
there's no discussion so I thought that
that's some of the stuff that I took
from it I would like to have seen more I
think the temple guy was interesting I
think and also you don't know sometimes
these people go in interviews and they
say there's things that they don't want
to talk about obviously you know Jack
Dorsey the guy you know he's an
innovator he's an innovator but yes you
want to watch need episode and and and
and and and see you know people's voices
are getting curbed in those places or
what your thoughts are on it but Tim
Poole man he showed up with a lot of
every time every time something's wrong
he showed up with a lot of uh he showed
up with a lot of points and he was
pointing you could feel his thoughts I'm
not sad look I'm not saying that I'm
buying his [ __ ] you know nudie
calendar or anything like that but I'm
saying that you could feel that the man
had done his homework he came he came
correct
he didn't sit back there behind uh you
know he came correct I thought he came
he came ready to discuss it seemed like
he really wanted to so and but then also
do what the [ __ ] do I know what do wanna
know brah anyway a little more news
Antonio Brown was traded to the Raiders
for third and fifth round picks and
renegotiated his salary to give him to
give him thirty million dollars
guaranteed over the next three years and
make him the NFL's highest-paid wide
receiver I you know Antonio Brown was in
the payment it mean he looked he
definitely had been making money but he
wasn't making a lot of money as in
comparison to other receivers and he was
the on paper he was one of the top two
or three so I could understand his anger
and his angst but it was it didn't seem
to be just about that
it seemed to me overtime that he
developed a real ego problem and the
egos dangerous I mean the ego is
something that lives inside of us you
know it's that dark heart and that [ __ ]
we know you [ __ ] leave a can of uh of
Herschel Williams not Herschel Williams
um you leave a can of uhm Sherwin
Williams lying around and that dark
artist will start to [ __ ] paint the
insides of you it'll it'll remodel the
insides of yourself because it that ego
man it's got a look it's got all the
brushes it knows just how to stroke you
and I'm it's gonna be interesting to see
how an Antonio Brown does out there in a
place where he doesn't have that
quarterback I felt like it was too much
ego and and I said this before I think a
lot of players in these sports now
they're there's so much more it doesn't
seem like anything's about the team
anymore a lot of times but then also if
you're in a team and that team is making
a ton of money you don't think that
they're sharing enough with you and I
can understand the guy wanting his money
I just wonder at the end of his life
when he looks back you know but
hindsight's 20/20 I wish him well man I
hope he has a new experience over there
with his teammates and and I hope we all
I hope we all get out of our egos if we
can what else can I tell you guys we
were adding some shows in San Jose in
two weeks Sunday shows at least one and
I want to thank everybody I'm so excited
about going over there man it's not far
it'll be less traveling a little less
stress in that way
I'm also April and that's more uh I
don't know when that is March 21st and
22nd and 23rd and maybe the 24th now
April 5th and 6th I'm in Kansas City
April 26th and 27th I'm in Palm Beach
West Palm Beach Florida May 3rd and 4th
at Caroline's in New York City what else
is going on with you guys how are you
feeling
how are you feeling you feeling ok I
hope you guys are doing good yeah
sometimes I guess I'm afraid to feel
good about myself you know I was talking
to a friend the other day and they say
you know you're so hard on yourself all
the time and I say yeah you know I think
because I think at some point in my life
if I wasn't hard on me it was just you
know I wasn't gonna let anybody else
tell me what to do
and so the only person who was gonna
tell me what to do was me and and I
didn't really know how to do that so the
ways I'd learn to do that were some of
the more healthy and some of them were
not and probably some of the ways that
were not or some of them that are still
you know embedded in me and those are
your that is some of that is one of the
blessings of living in a time where we
can do a self-examination and you know
seek help and talk to friends and I mean
we are at a special time where we can
delve in you know we're there's drugs
out there that people use to get go deep
and there's you know there's and there's
meditation it's like even though a lot
of has been around for a long time I
think a lot of that kind of stuff is
coming back more psychedelics than
cocaine you know more meditation then uh
than just relying on things outside of
us to to help us excavate within us so I
see a lot of that and you know those are
things I want to learn about myself and
so some of the stuff I talk about
sometimes it's just so I can try and
think you know I can just try and and
not think but feel you know a lot of my
life I didn't have any feelings I was
just operating out here I just was
operating as action and reaction and
nothing was coming from a place
internally that really was connecting to
me I wasn't connecting to anything I was
doing okay but in the inside I wasn't
really connect
thing to anything even to myself and
that's not the case for me now and now
man you know now I'm you know I've been
working and doing some of the work and
trying to stay involved in places and
groups and around people that that I can
have a different experience with myself
and a new one I mean in some ways I felt
like a five-year-old you know with all
of his emotions in his arms and all of
his his insides and stuff just wandering
around or yeah but a strong
five-year-old you know cuz he bought
that [ __ ] he bowed about it man I
wanted to be home for Mardi Gras last
week I really wanted to be there what
else can I tell you God you know I'm
just so tired I don't want to down I
want to you know hold you guys too long
I'm trying to think of some other people
like him out dude so let me tell you who
came out to one of the shows
triplets brah you know what I'm saying
dude sometimes the womb stutters a
little bit and it makes but babies you
know it makes them [ __ ] bad boys dude
in these guys it was like there was a
little Neapolitan sandwich man I did
these boys they were beautiful boys and
they all they would finish each other's
sentence one of them would start to
blink a little then one of them would
blink a little more than one of them
would fully blink and I was like
wouldn't the [ __ ] is going on and these
boys were just a living batch of dark
art if you see if you see these fellows
they're over there near I Atlantic City
I think they came out in and they there
was triplets and they said dude we're
triplets and I was like [ __ ] what
dude the singers and they're like what
and they said no we were all born at the
same time I said damn y'all that [ __ ]
batch y'all that batch and they would do
it was crazy man they would you know you
tell one of them a joke and the other
one would [ __ ] laugh man even
listening to him it was like playing you
know conversating with him it was like
just-just dialogue dialogue you know
just like dialogical whack-a-mole you
know you'd be over here with an answer
and then BAM the question no and then
you know it was unique it was like
playing the shell game you know you ever
come out of a supermarket and they got
that brother out there with the
cardboard and he got the little nutmegs
right there and one of them's got a
little long
you know little nugget of coke or
something under or a little pecan and
he's flipping those things around and
bouncing them with the carts and next
thing you know we think you over here
talking about shellfish and then BAM
[ __ ] contestant number three hits you
with a [ __ ] conversation about zoning
in his area you're like what the [ __ ]
and that you would triplet you got to
stay alert with triplet you really got
it's almost like you got to do one at a
time you know you got to do like this
what's up duh what's up dude you know
hey buddy how are you and you so you got
a section them off by their dead look
they were beautiful boys they all looked
pretty healthy and um and I told them
straight up I said hey look if you guys
are like the Transformers or whatever
like because I'm thinking these dudes
are gonna do to do autobot [ __ ] one of
them gets into a little set you know a
set of legs and then one of them torso
is up and the third one [ __ ] morphs
into a head and then they wander off
just one guy working over there but a
[ __ ] you know about a Jersey Mike's
or the FedEx Kinkos
but it's why when you meet him if you
see if you see triplets man you just let
them know you support them do your best
that's all we can do
I'm tired man I love you I would stay
longer and chat with you I want to be
able to reflect on more experiences that
I had this week and let me take one or
two more calls here they go the number
is always nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we do I believe
have a single-mother lockdown for
Phoenix and one for San Jose as well so
I'm really excited about that
we want to do you know we want to do
some big things this this year in that
space and and thank you guys in our
patreon supporters who support who
support a lot of that onward here we go
CEO Jersey to step back to show a
Borgata
what's up Anthony oh I appreciate you
calling man this is cool
onwards Atlantic City my first comedy
show ever man and you and already killed
it so uh thank you for that man you've
got throwing a great show I decided to
bring my mom with me give her a nice
night out we had a great time man it was
cool sharing laughs was there there's
nice bonding with it we don't get to do
that a lot so it was nice taking
arriving and sharing those laughs you
know and then when you said you're doing
the the mean Bria for the show man I was
pumped like you got a whip gotta wait in
the line to the phone in each and then
and then when we were leaving
biggie whenever mama went over to my mom
and gave her a hug and a kiss and I
think you said you know take care take
care of your son I was like this you
know this is a nice thing to my think
the same man shows that genuine genuine
you are and thought that was cool man I
look forward to seeing other showing the
future
mmm be good to yourself man Garin the
gang brah Thank You Man the sweetie to
say I think I might remember I do
remember we have one woman came out and
she had six children and she brought her
youngest daughter out she had bright red
lipstick on I remember that pair and
then they had another man with his mom
she had kind of short blonde hair and uh
and I didn't know if it was his date or
something because you know they got all
of that stuff online you know you see it
with these ladies I thought they you
know this might be his schoolteacher
this could be a damn ninth grader and
you know she's a lady that does the
algebra and they just you know going to
the casino for the weekend but um but
yeah I do remember that and it's nice
man it's cool you know my mother and
I've never had that experience I mean
she came to the show and I taped my
Netflix special and and actually she may
be coming to my show in Phoenix in a
couple weeks because she lives in Tucson
now
so I'm excited about that
but yeah it always uh you know I think
there's something there's just a look
man I'm just glad you guys came and I'm
glad to have been a part of it you know
I'm glad that makes me feel good to
think that you guys sit there laughing
together and some of it's awkward and
some of it's not awkward and you know in
little moments you learn about each
other and you know I think for a mother
to get to hear her son laughs and a son
to get to hear her mother laugh you know
that's just I just I can't imagine when
we go to like a different place you know
after this life that that's not that
whatever the place we go to isn't made
out of just that sound and that that
moment whatever that is you know and I'm
not saying that because I'm part of it
you know because I work in the laughter
business I'm just saying it because uh
you know I just imagine that's something
like that has to be the truth you know
and so I appreciate you guys coming out
and that was sweet of you to bring your
mom out and if I didn't recall you guys
correctly I'm sorry bye
onward let's take another call here we
have one more hey there but I was
running from Florida beer I'm from
Florida do what's up Playboy and you out
there by the beach you over there in the
riffraff country son that riffraff a
dactyl boy and if y'all knew riff raff
is man this is a dude he's [ __ ]
growing tangerines inside of his inside
of his dungarees dude he's that fruit
he's that um you know he's he's that pro
he's producing you feel me
this dude's got [ __ ] veggies if out
of that vegetation nation bro he
sprouting sprouts
you know he's that guy he's always up to
something and he's that lean Gene
Okerlund let's hear more and hear coming
on West Palm Beach Florida but thing is
I'm the only 15 years old so dang
brah well let me just make sure there's
nothing on the shelves or anything
that's profane or anything like that
underneath it of plastic [ __ ] or
whatever I don't know what premature
Nick is doing in here in the daytime you
know you're only 15 I was 15 once man
let me see onward you have to be 21 good
one yourselves so I think I might you
know get a little trench coat or
something got on someone's shoulders and
get in that way but don't tell anyone I
had that love you too man damn for a
15-year old you sound like you got you
know you sound like you got all like you
probably got some pretty large nuts on
your bra and I don't mean that and you
might not even [ __ ] I should have said
that [ __ ] you sound like a healthy male
that's what you sound like
and I bet you know you see my can you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you can't talk to
children like that you know so here's
what I'm saying thank you for calling if
you do the trench coat look man go deep
with a big idea bra you know get some
borrow some hair off of somebody cut a
little bit of curl off one of your
Latino buddies or a Jewish buddy you
know D throw them a little bit off the
back and [ __ ] you make a beard dude I
would love to see you slowly evolving
into uh you know what what can we do you
to make you look like an adult to get
you into that show but you got to do
some of the work mm-hmm
you know you still got like six weeks so
maybe yeah you got to borrow some
sideburns or something and maybe get a
mustache and do different stuff we'll
see anything could happen
but I wish you were you know I'm happy
you're at the age you are and maybe one
day I can do something for you know
people that are underage and we do a
show or they're you know there's no
profanity or in it like that but if
you're looking to have a good time if I
can pop into some of those old episodes
of nine oh two one oh that'll make you
feel good also everybody through this
show I want to meet this man Chris
Lilley when I go to Australia and he's
one of my favorite entertainers him and
Gerry Clower - my favorite
of all time and Richard Pryor's and if
you go look at him he they have a show
called Summer Heights High Volume one
start there it's on YouTube it'll look a
little weird like the how small it is
when you start playing it but you will
love that show you will love it it'll be
the best show you've never seen and it's
called Summer Heights High you can find
it on YouTube
and then you send that man Adam and tell
him I'd love to meet him when I'm
Australia and and have him be a guest on
here um I just want to thank you guys
thank you for coming out in Atlantic
City thank you for coming out in Boston
thank you for coming out in Medford
it was exciting man it was like a first
you know and I'm not always gonna be in
theaters or nothing like that man I want
to be in places where it's easier to
meet the audience I couldn't meet people
after the first show in Medford because
they have to start the second show so
there was no time there's no place so
some of that kind of occurs and you know
I know some of its kind of impersonal
but it wasn't impersonal to me and and
we'll find ways to make it more personal
in the future and I want to thank
everybody I tried to meet everybody do
it after the Atlantic City show me we
must have like 300 people man and it was
great dude people would have one girl
she wasn't she was probably an alcoholic
they had um this one young lady drove
him from New York right after work and
uh and she and I got to get a picture
together
we had some people that was in the
Merchant Marines that came out we had a
young men that was about to go off to
boot camp who came out we had this mix
they had these three dudes that had the
craziest hair I've ever seen one guy he
had that you know that uh he had that
Jamaican that hammock you know sometimes
you'll see fellas with that Jamaican
hammock hitter and they got their hair
all wrapped up and then the next thing
you know they're you know then they
[ __ ] untie their hair and a [ __ ]
little you know two acres of Barbados
falls out and on one of the acres they
grow in that puff and he had and I had
another friend that had this straight up
Frederick Douglass [ __ ] top hit her
hair and then their third do was this
little this white guy and he straight-up
had that
that Vince Neil he had that [ __ ] his
[ __ ] was cold-pressed bro his [ __ ] was
you know it was I mean he had just
French press that just flat ironed his
hair right it was it was the most
remarkable hair trifecta that I'd ever
seen man so kudos to those boys who else
came out that I can do and I'm not
trying to pick people out I just can't
remember right now my brain is tired and
and I'm gonna go and get some rest huh
you guys thank you so much man
be good to yourselves I know that you
deserve it and and and just thank you
man I'm just so grateful like you know
I've realized the other day I think part
of the reason why I was feeling kind of
sad is just I just realized I get to
live my dreams and like and I want to
live like a person that is deserving of
that gift because I know some people may
not be able to do that and I want to you
know I just want to be you know and I
know people tell you all the time he
meant thanks for the nice things you do
and I know I hear that but if I'm
healthy and I am capable and then I want
to be able to do all that I can you know
and because that makes me feel good when
I really think about other things make
me feel good you know you know sexual
you know uh you know doing cocaine you
know um you know what else
slides doing the slides at the park you
know watching my [ __ ] friend Daniel
Braves some money one time dude and uh
and uh he was gonna donate blood dude
but he [ __ ] took it out at his house
and tried to bring it over there and it
was like the last hundred dollars he
needed and he was gonna get a like a
skateboard or one of the
um he was like a pogo stick or something
and they [ __ ] Brady went over there
were like a half a cup of our [ __ ]
body you know you know that body sauce
and they [ __ ] shut him down dude and
called child services you know so if I
can't even what I'm talking about man
but I love you guys man be good
yourselves I know that you deserve it
man I know that I knew it from the
second I met most of you and I'll always
know that you know I will always know
that
[Music]
there's that same band Bishop Gunn with
their song all the ways
[Music]
love you guys man be good
[Applause]
[Music]